Hey whats up my friends!
its the next day and the silicone has cured
now i was a little worried
because last night before bed
I tested the silicone and it was still gooey
even after 12 hours of setting
now researching this catalyst
I found it that it takes 4 times longer for it to set
than the other catalysts we used in the past
which made me a little bit nervous that they wouldn't be ready today
but checking them out now, they are very firm
very rubbery
and so I am relatively confident
it's okay to cut them open and extract the brains
if not, I guess we're gonna find out what happens with uncured silicone
now yesterday when we poured the silicone, we had a bit of an issue
where the brain started rising
so we used these screws
to hold them down
i used a little but of ductape
just hold the silicone in until it set
and it looks like it did a really good job
so looking here you can see parts of the brain
still stuck to the bottom
that means our scwew did its job and it held the brain in place
the cool thing about using containers like this for our molds
the edes are slidely tapered downwards
so when we get the sides released
we should theoretically be able to turn it over
and have it plop right down on the table
*plop*
yeah
look what I have created
brain molds
huh
kinda looks like a giant mochi
*laughs*
so cool
our big silicone blocks
are out of the molds
it looks like there pritty firm
so I am relatively confident
we are gonna get a good brain mold today
so lets grab some paper towel and an Exacto knife
and set our minds free
ewww
there we go its very nice
oh yummy, bits of brain stuck on there
Ha
yeagh?
*laughs*
I think some of that flew in my mouth
so, I spent a good deal of time cutting this thing now
I have made 5 different incisions
where we can peel this all away
at this point, I think
we may be able to reach down
and pull that sucker out
ehhhhh *laughs*
awww yea there we go
mostly recoverd
it looks like
this little piece at the back here
got choped off
thats still inside
wich means we need to cut those little
strands that a holding it back
because when we cast anything else
it ganna follow the same pattern
and we don't want our chocolate
or gummies to be breaking
ehhhhh
lets see if i can piece this thing back together
it's like a puzzle!
it's like a brain teaser
this is your brain
this is your brain on silicone
my eyes are watering, my nose
burning, i thing that's the formaldehyde bleeding
through, OK this is where it gets a little nasty
*laughs* we can look down inside
and look at that
that' pretty hard work
you can tell that because i'm sweating
ah ya it's getting a lot easier now
were almost there the end is it sight
aw man that is slightly disturbing
you know what this thing kind of reminds me of?
are those old ninja turtle cartoons remember that character krang who has a little like a little pink brain that looks a lot like krang I think
that's a little disturbing
eww brains
so there we did it guys
we successfully got our brain out
we got a cool rubber  silicone mold
the only problem with it is that if you look on the inside its got all these disgusting gooey bits of brain and blood vessels
stuck to the inside and also smells bad too
so i got a big bucket of dish soap and bleach
we are going to scrub these things and let them soak for about a hour or two
and while we are waiting we are going to answer a comment request from Andy Varcho
Andy asks "What would happen to a brain in a vacuum chamber? Would you be able to get a cows brain?"
well not only can we Andy we actually did.
these are genuine real cow brains
and we are going to put them inside this vacuum chamber for you right now
I just noticed this is the brain that was floating
up in the silicon and i pressed it back down with my
finger and you can actually see the finger marks
the indentations in the brain from the pressure
i had to put on it
i was hoping that would re-inflate but apparently it doesn't.
So Andy we are doing this for you
we got our brain set in the vacuum chamber
all we have to do now is switch on the pump
and see if anything happens
here we go
I don't really see anything happening.
Ok lets exhaust it and see if anything happens
exhausting the brain in 3, 2 , 1
Oh actually it did deflate a little bit.
well that was suprising
Lets try it again and watch this
Alright that is at full pressure lets let the air back in
In 3, 2
yea we can see it shrink down a little bit
it's not anything super impressive but it is something
yep very very minimal
So i am glad we didn't spend a whole lot of time on that
But don't worry Andy i'm still sending you twenty-five bucks(Dollars)
because it was a worthy experiment and you never
know unless you try
So now we know
So brain in a vacuum chamber doesn't really do much
And i don't have much other use for these brains
so i think i am just going to take my finger
and stick it down inside to see what kind of experience
i can gleam from that
Now i am just running my finger over the top of the brain
which i haven't done yet because i didn't want to disrupt
this for the silicon mold
And
It kind of just feels like (uh) chicken actually
it feels like bumpy chicken
but you can see now that it doesn't have that top
membrane on we can actually pull these crevices apart
and amazingly the silicon didn't leak down inside
So it must have been relatively tight
Now if i get down inside one of these crevices here
push down inside
it's kind of firm
it's kind of like pushing a finger through a piece of rubber
its starting to give way And...
I'm out the otherside
right there
Alright
Well that was interesting now we can just break
this away and see what the interior(inside) looks like
Kind of looks like a mushroom
I mean i like mushrooms and i hope this doesn't gross
anyone else out who does but
look at that cross-section. That looks a lot like a mushroom
And surprisingly the texture is much like a mushroom
as well
wow it makes me wonder how smart mushrooms must be
what i have always wanted to do is take one of these brains
and just split it in half
and this is what it looks like
how interesting
how much does it take to break it
not much ok
so this is kind of just like one giant mushroom
and thats what it feels like
its got the sponginess of a mushroom stem
the top parts here feel a lot like a mushroom
and you can kind of see its even kind of slimy
ok so this brain is destroyed and we have learned a lot
i'm just going to take this and squish it just because we can
oh goodness
its like play-doh
it doesn't stick like play-doh but it squish like play-doh
oh wow
huh
that is really interesting
because there is nothing left you just squish it and it completely  pulverizes
look at that
it is kind of disturbing isn't it
Wow...So...
(Laughs)
yeah i am going to get grossed out now
i think i am done playing with brains
that was enough that was fun very educational but i am done
and i need to change my gloves
so here we are guys i feel like we learned a lot about the brain today
and not only that we have some cool rubber molds that I
am going to let soak in bleach over night and make sure they
are completely clean because i have a higher and better use
for them coming right up. I actually pre-made some purple
and green gummy that we are going to melt down and pour
into these molds simultaneously to see if we can make ourselves
some purple and green gummy zombie brains
how cool would that be
that will be coming up in the next video and of course a big
thanks to Andy Varcho for requesting a brain in a vacuum chamber
go ahead and check your YouTube inbox i am sending you twenty-five bucks(dollars)
Thanks for joining me for this experiment, i will be looking
for you in the next Project. Talk to you then
ho grants getting weird out
(slam sound effect)
Hey guys thanks for watching and remember i am giving away
prizes away now in every new video
all you have to do to qualify is subscribe to my channel
ring the bell and select to be notified when my next videos get released
the secret link to my give away  will be pinned in the comments
for the first twelve hours
if you like what i am doing show your support right now by giving
this video a big thumbs up and share it with a friend
i love you back and i will see you next time